so the democrats are boasting about
biden's economy but the average american
is facing a very different reality job
gains hidden above the mark of 428 000
added last month but soaring inflation
continues to rise the cost
of everything james carville says upset
americans don't understand just how good
the economy is right now watch
i think there's an entire picture of an
economy here and i don't think that the
people in america are getting
understanding completely what it is
there are there are some bad things but
if we're making these decisions off the
faulty assumptions that no job decreed
that's just not true
he even lost cnn they believe the
analysis is just baloney watch
on the chiron you see dismal i was going
to use the word awful essentially if you
ask americans how they view the economy
is it poor or good it is 77 say bad bad
bad just 23 say good you got to all go
all the way back to 2012 to see numbers
that bad and it's not much of a surprise
if you ask folks what's the most
important problem facing the country
right now what is the top issue the
economy
yikes
and if rising costs aren't enough of a
headache now the supply chain crisis
hitting parents who say they can't find
formula to feed their babies kayla
you're a mom
um
do you think this is going to swing
women voters to the republican side
based on this issue no absolutely not i
mean that is a real phenomenon women who
can't afford diapers i have a friend who
helps out a charity to provide diaper
swimming that's how bad the economy is
right now but uh it's a different story
if you go on chief of staff ron clayne's
twitter feed the last eight hours ron
claim has retweeted 19 tweets saying how
great the economy is just to sample
another strong jobs number one hell of a
graph and it's all true solid jobs
report you know at a certain point the
lady doth protest too much to quote
shakespeare and that is exactly what
ronclain is doing because one number
matters it's the one percent who think
the economy is excellent i don't know
who the one percent is maybe jeff bezos
but that's the number that matters is
what people feel yeah
do you think carol it is a communication
flaw or is it just a reality they got to
deal with what they're working with they
can't spend this number
no you never want to try to tell people
that they're doing better than they
think that they're doing um i think what
james was saying was
we have some fundamentals and we've got
to figure out how to frame a message and
then tell the american people share with
the american people what we're doing to
fix the problem you you touched on one
or two of the things crime
uh in the border things we have to get
not only a message around
but put a policy in place that the
american people are going to have
confidence in i've shared on this show
if i were the president once a week i'd
be in a city with a d.a judge i'd be
with the police chief i'd come back to
washington saying these are the things
we have to help cities like the ones i
just visited what they're asking about
what we need cash cash bail reform more
police officers on the street
providing
mental health services
and when it comes to the economy look
we've got to invest in cities that are
going to create new jobs and attract
jobs so how do you bring more 5g how do
you ensure that we can produce potato
chips and semiconductor chips here in
america how do we ensure that we don't
fall behind china and producing
batteries if i were the white house i'd
be talking about these things that's
what i interpreted from james remember
james carnival gave democrats the
greatest sign we had in the 90s it's the
economy stupid the white house had to
listen judge it seems like the democrats
have a lot on their plate i mean when
you're a prosecutor you're trying to
give someone a break if they got all
these charges there's only so much you
can do to work with them right yeah i
don't want to work with them if they
have that many charges but that's
another issue here's the problem the
problem is that inflation is is is
raging like never before inflation has
gone up by eight and a half percent
wages are gone up by five percent this
is a government that is
disincentivizing
work and and disinfect incentivizing
jobs all right they're incentivizing
people to stay home and to not go to
work and just pay students for their
loans for no reason when there are
eleven and a half million jobs available
and only six million people looking for
a job so it's the incentivizing and the
disincentivizing that this this this
government is involved in and what
they're done with the oil and gas and
everything else is they basically shut
down the growth we've already got one
quarter with a 1.4 drop if we have
another quarter with another drop we're
in a recession all right i'm not a
genius and i'm not an economist but i
know that so don't tell me everything's
going great i don't care how you frame
it the bottom line is people are hurting
people are hungry people are assessing
medicine jobs house rent it's bad greg
it just seems like they insult the
voters
when when they have no more argument
instead of just confessing and saying
well turn it around they say don't
believe your own eyes or your pocketbook
yeah you i don't know if they can turn
it around i you know this uh
the shortage of baby formula what is joe
biden going to have for lunch
you know
thank god there are no shortages in
stuff that i eat and drink i check that
it's the great consumer index and the
writ
in chinese ribs fine red wine fine
this this uh
this baby formula thing though i did not
know about it until jessica told me and
it's like imagine you have i mean it's
like this is something that like if
you're just it's i'm getting to a point
i think if you're disassociated or
detached from a problem you know you
don't sometimes you just don't even know
it exists and
it reminds me of how detached
people in the media were with with the
covet shutdowns
or the effects of the economy or the
effects of crime because you know you
never you've got security where you work
and stuff like that affects the food
shortages and the media could sustain a
lot of this stuff especially the
shutdowns because we just worked our way
through it we didn't we just could get
studios at home and and so people are
hurting but the same people in the media
they have the means to absorb
the pain that others don't same thing
with crime their answer to crime is two
words it's you know gated community what
scares me
uh in the future is this war and the
effects of the war on future food
shortages if we're already having
problems right now and we're all in on
this thing man and
every country is going to feel it
especially the poor ones like africa um
and i think that
when you have food shortages and this is
what dana's explained to me on a number
of occasions it usually does lead to
more war a lot of the countries that go
to war go to work because they don't
have the food so we're having this
conflict going on right now which could
create severe food shortages which will
then lead to more war it might be a good
time to start figuring out a negotiated
settlement before it gets really really
bad that's my
i think the biggest story here is is the
media and we saw this doing covet of
saying that we're all in this together
americans felt differently and they
eventually turned on the media i think
it's going to be the same for this issue
as well hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else